Todas las excusas que ha puesto el partido popular
para no renovar el consejo general del poder judicial,
en funciones desde 04/12/2018.
Hace más de 4 años
que el partido popular
bloquea la renovación del consejo general
del poder judicial.
Alguien nos estaba mintiendo.
Durante la negociación del consejo general
del poder judicial,
la última y 20ª excusa,
la reforma del delito de sedición.
Rebajar el delito de sedición es romper
la unidad de los españoles ante la ley.
Mejor romper 1 acuerdo
que traicionar a España.
No se puede pactar
la renovación del órgano de gobierno
de los jueces
con quien pretende ahora, con esta reforma,
dejar sin efecto las resoluciones de los jueces.
En 2 020 el partido popular rompía las negociaciones
y se escudaba en qué
podemos era 1 partido que atacaba la monarquía.
Han pedido que el Rey aplique que me está pidiendo
que aún así yo me sienta a pactar con ellos.
La justificación más usada por el PP
fue la de la presencia de podemos en el gobierno.
Podemos ha doblado la apuesta
y les exigen estar en esta negociación.
Casado. Exigía que solo PP y PSOE
tomaran parte de la negociación.
Ningún otro partido
tiene que formar parte de esa negociación.
Cuando se está hablando de cosas serias
se necesitan partidos serios.
Tampoco les gustó el nombramiento de Dolores delgado
como fiscal general del estado.
La fiscal general del estado
propuesta por Pedro Sánchez,
no reúne los requisitos y de unidad
porque la legislación Española le exige
la imparcialidad
que 1 diputada,
a día de hoy del partido socialista no tiene,
cuando en diciembre de 2 020
el PSOE
propuso limitar las funciones del consejo caducado
para que no pudiera hacer nombramientos
en la cúpula judicial.
Casado llegó a denominar la propuesta 1 atropello legal.
Mientras no retire ese atropello legal
no hay nada que pactar.
Paso que dieron ayer es 1 vuelta de tuerca más
no es 1 mano tendida del gobierno,
es 1 mano obligada.
En 2 021 el PP llevó al congreso 1 proposición de ley
para que fueran los propios jueces
quienes eligieran a los vocales del consejo,
pero el Parlamento lo tumbó.
1 propuesta normativa
que permita a los jueces ser elegidos
entre los propios jueces.
El PP vetó a Vicky Russell y José Ricardo de Prada,
jueces de la órbita de podemos,
con la excusa de que se politizaba el órgano.
Las personas que no cumplan los requisitos
no pueden formar parte del consejo del poder judicial,
y 1 de los requisitos
es la despolitización del consejo general.
Es es 1 insulto a la inteligencia
que lo diga el partido popular,
que siempre ha elegido
eh cargos eh políticos dentro de la
de la judicatura más que ningún otro partido,
y ahora mismo
preside el consejo general del poder judicial
y el Tribunal supremo
alguien que fue 1 cargo
con el partido popular,
como si esto sí se permitiera y los demás no.
En 2022 el PSOE presentó 1 proposición De ley
para que el consejo
pudiera elegir a 2 miembros
del Tribunal Constitucional.
Pese a estar en funciones el PPD,
Feijó lo criticó duramente
y presentó 1 recurso ante el propio constitucional.
Ahora le repone parte de sus competencias
que previamente le había Hurtado
para controlar el tribunal constitucional.
El PP luchaba por no perder la mayoría
tanto en el constitucional como en el consejo.
La prensa de derechas
llegó a afirmar
que el gobierno presionaba a Carlos Lesmes,
Presidente del consejo y del supremo,
prometiéndole 1 puesto en el constitucional.
Me parece que inevitablemente la ministra de justicia
tiene que Dar unas explicaciones de forma inmediata
si no las ha dado ya
y tiene que desmentir
que se esté presionando al Presidente
del consejo y del Tribunal supremo.
Quizás eh el Presidente Sánchez
le preocupe menos el estado que a mí.
¿Y por qué tantas excusas?
El PP ha buscado impedir 1 mayoría progresista
en el constitucional
y en el órgano de gobierno de los jueces
mientras desgastaba al gobierno de coalición